an even number is the number that is
divisible by two numbers like 2 4 6 and
so on are even numbers then what are
odds they are numbers which are not
divisible by two numbers like 1 3 5 and
so on
how does GMAT make this topic
interesting trust me there are many ways
look at this question for instance 4 is
a factor of X is X even and suddenly a
simple topic looks confusing it's simple
all we really need to do is read the
question well and decode it the number 4
can be reduced to 2 times 2 based on the
factor tree approach we had seen we can
say that if 4 is a factor of x + 2 is a
factor of 4 then 2 will also be a factor
of X it means X is divisible by 2 which
tells us that X is even or we can
probably say that if X is divisible by a
multiple of 2 then X is surely even
here's another one
y is equal to 34 times n where N is a
natural number is y odd look at the
number 34 reducing it to its prime
factors it can be written as 2 times 17
so 34 n will be 2 times 17 times
something what does this tell us we can
be sure that it is divisible by 2 no
matter what that something is Y will
surely be divisible by 2 or we can also
say that Y is a multiple of 2 in any
case we can be sure that Y is even and
not odd do we get special results when
we add or subtract odd and even numbers
let's look at addition first look at it
logically only three cases can exist
even plus even odd plus odd or even plus
odd for each of these three cases there
can be three possibilities we may get an
even number or an odd number or maybe
get nothing specific at all an even plus
even example would be something like two
plus four even plus even we get a six
which is an even number let's say we add
six and ten which are even numbers we
get sixteen which is an even number no
matter what even numbers you consider
their sum will always be even what about
odd plus odd look at these two examples
one plus three and five plus seven both
cases gave us an even number addition of
odd numbers will also result in an even
number even plus odd here are a couple
of examples for even plus odd yes both
result in an odd number will it be
different for subtraction for
subtraction as well there will be three
cases even - even odd - odd and even -
odd an example of even - even would be 6
- 2 that gives us 4 or 12 - 6 which also
gives us an even number even - even will
always give us an even number and you
can see that odd - odd will also give us
an even number look at the even - odd
examples both result in an odd number
and odd - even will also result in an
odd number this tells us that when we
add or subtract the same type of numbers
we will get an even number however if we
perform addition or subtraction
on two different types of numbers we
will arrive upon an odd number